لذلك أنا في منتصف الاحتجاج
الذي يحدث في بكين ، لقد
تجاوزت الساعة الواحدة صباحًا فقط ، وهناك حشد من
الشباب معظمهم اجتمعوا هنا
للاحتجاج على الإجراءات السرية في الصين ،
وكانوا يرددون لا ليطمعوا في اختبارات
نعم للحرية و  يحدث هذا في
منطقة Talion ، حيث يوجد مركز
تفشي الطمع في بكين
حيث حثوا جميع السكان على البقاء
في المنزل ، لذلك من غير
المسبوق حقًا أن نرى مثل هذا
الحشد الكبير من الناس هنا الكثير من
الناس  كما ترون أنهم
يحملون هذه القطع الورقية البيضاء ،
فهذا رمز
لمناهضة الرقابة ورأينا أيضًا
احتجاجًا في شنغهاي رأينا
متظاهرين يحملون هذه القطع الورقية البيضاء
الآن في هذه المنطقة وكذلك هنا
هناك  العديد من السفارات الأجنبية ،
بما في ذلك السفارة الأمريكية
هناك ، ومن الجدير بالذكر أنهم اختاروا هذا
الموقع لهذا الاحتجاج الآن ،
وقد استمر هذا الاحتجاج بالفعل لعدة
ساعات ، فقد فات الأوان لرؤية
الشرطي الآن.  يطلب مني
التراجع قليلاً ، لكن هناك
تواجدًا كبيرًا للشرطة ، فهم في الواقع
في هذا الصف بأكمله عبارة عن صف كامل من
رجال الشرطة ، لكنه احتجاج سلمي
حتى الآن ، يمكنك سماع
الهتاف للسيارات التي تهتف وهي تقود أيضًا
مرتين بشكل متكرر  إنهم
يتضامنون مع الناس هنا لا
يبدو أنهم ذاهبون إلى أي مكان في أي وقت قريبًا